we have to check in with each other over
and over and over again to make sure
that the conditions of our relationships
are up to speed
a lot of times couples for example they
have certain expectations or agreements
for the relationship and then they never
check in with each other for the next
five years or ten years you know and
it's like wait like you're the the
Agreements are changing people always
say and want to feel seen they want to
feel heard it can be very confronting to
see another when what is being asked to
be seen requires that person to then see
that in themselves oh man yeah when
we're talking about being seen scene you
know that like the nuanced scene we're
talking about uh someone really deeply
connecting to the experience